yeah now you obviously had a 15-year NBA
career
um when you guys were playing how much
did you actually pay attention to the
Talking Heads to the sports talk shows
it was different you know I mean because
I think I came in the league in the
early 2000s yeah I mean so it was but
maybe like the last five or six years it
was so it got it was a part of that era
yeah I think I retired at 17. so the
wave it kind of already hit but now it's
you know it always continues to evolve
but you hear it you mean no matter what
anyone says you hear everything and I
remember getting a chance to interview
Kobe on our show and we asked him you
know because he was criticized so much I
was like you know what what criticism
hurt the most he said all of them he's
like I heard all of them you know what I
mean so and someone is locked in and
focused on what he's supposed to do like
no matter what a player says he hears
and everything yeah and they take it in
I think I think that's with anybody
right but see I used to be the opposite
like I used to be
the guy that would you know be on the
table getting stretched or getting
treatment before the game and looking on
Twitter for people talking [ __ ] to me
just to kind of motivate me more you
know what I mean like like use it as
kind of like a chip or like continue to
light the fire just you know to to to to
to to say [ __ ] you to to the haters but
it's a lot man you know and everyone
kind of handles it the way they handle
it but uh
the just it's a 24-hour news cycle they
always need news that's why I think the
quality of news has gone down because it
has so much of it it has for sure I
think I mean of course not even Just
Sports yeah in general and I think too
like you know this probably more than
anyone like I think the networks have
all figured out what generates ratings
is these debate shows
so as soon as you wake up you got Nick
right and then you got Skip and Shannon
and then you got Colin Cowherd and then
you got so it's like it's almost like
what CNN figured out 10 years prior is
like if we just have people on TV
arguing yeah no question it's going to
be a lot more better for the bottom line
than if we actually just have people
analyzing the game and showing
highlights it's all about raidens that's
all it's about it's about views eyeballs
ratings